football threw out us a curveball today
because we were kind of at the point
where we accepted the reality
that the eagles had one suitor for
carson wentz and that
until march 17 when the deal officially
can be done there was no reason for
either side to move toward the bottom
line apparently both sides became
sufficiently exasperated with the
uncertainty and they decided to get the
deal done and they did get the deal done
as of march 17 at 4 pm eastern carson
wentz will be traded to the indianapolis
colts for a 2021 third round pick and a
second round pick in 2022 that becomes a
first rounder if
carson wentz participates in 75 percent
of the steps on offense or
70 plus they make it to
the playoffs which creates an intriguing
doughnut hole that if they stink near
the
75 mark of the season maybe they tell
carson wentz to take a seat so they
don't have to give up a first-round pick
for 2022 but uh look i'm not surprised
by any of this i'm not surprised it's
the colts i'm not surprised that it
isn't a huge haul in return and i i am
just a little bit surprised that they
found a way to get the deal done with
just about four weeks to go until the
deal can be official sheree
yeah mike you know it's surprising but
it's not surprising and you think back
to a year maybe two five years ago
however long you want to go back
these quarterback deals are
unprecedented i mean we used to see
quarterbacks be drafted in the first
round and they were with that team until
they could no longer play whether that
was they just were terrible or they were
tired or they got hurt or whatever the
situation may be but we just didn't see
this kind of deals for
top level quarterbacks or what we think
can be top level quarterbacks or who
have shown they have been top level
quarterbacks at one point but guys who
are still in the prime of their careers
who are either young 30s like matthew
stafford or late 20s as is the case of
carson wentz and so i think that's why
it's surprising is just this shift of so
much quarterback movement even tom brady
last year in phillip rivers leaving us
free agents you know you didn't see that
a whole bunch in the past and we're just
seeing quarterbacks move around now it's
a different day a different game a
different time mike
i think a big part of it too is that as
more and more young quarterbacks come
into the sport
and pan out for whatever reason they're
more prepared or the game is more
prepared for them the coaches are more
flexible about doing the things that the
young quarterbacks did well at college
instead of saying we're going to take
this guy and make him into a quarterback
who runs a different system than what he
ran in college it's all about finding
the things that he can do coaching him
up quickly and getting him to reach his
potential sooner rather than later we
see a higher success rate for young
quarterbacks especially first rounders
makes it easier to say we're going to
move on from carson wentz we feel good
enough about jalen hurts that we can
move on from carson wentz maybe the
eagles think they can find somebody with
the sixth overall pick in the draft this
year who could come in and be that other
quarterback to jaylen hurts one thing
they learned through the carson wentz
era is you gotta have two guys you gotta
have two guys and the eagles regard
backup quarterback as a top 15 position
on their roster so they're not going to
stand pat with jalen hurts and nate
sudfeld they're going to get somebody
else and they've indicated there will be
competition for jalen hurts so he hasn't
been handed the starting job as of week
one the only thing we know is carson
wentz won't be one of the guys in
competition because wence didn't want
that wence believed that he should be
the unquestioned guy by virtue of the
contract that he received and you know
it's a strange story they trade up to
get him
they keep him over nick foles after the
2018 season when foles is super bowl mvp
and then that following year nearly gets
them back to the final four and then
they give wence the big contract two
seasons later here we are
they're doing everything they can to get
out from under that contract and moving
on from carson once it's strange how
they got there but in past years i agree
with you there wouldn't even be a
conversation about moving carson wentz
you keep him because once you have a guy
who has shown he can play like that
you don't let him go because you never
know when the next one is coming along
it seems like there's always a next one
coming along in today's nfl
and it's funny mike if you think back
even a year ago
they didn't have jalen hurts on their
roster right we would have thought this
was crazy even a year ago before they
drafted jalen hurts and i think that
jalen hurts
second round pick using that on him i
think that changed everything for the
eagles it changed their entire future it
changed everything for carson wentz
perhaps led to his loss of confidence
whatever happened there but something
happened this year with carson wentz and
now the colts get a chance to rebuild
that one thing i had forgotten mike and
you brought this up is how much the
eagles paid and i don't mean in money
because we know they paid a lot of money
to to
for carson wentz only a couple years ago
i'm talking about draft picks they give
up five draft picks in two different
trades to trade up to get this guy
number two overall and those draft picks
turned out to be desean watson laramie
tunzell and jack conklin among the five
draft picks so you think about those
guys you could have had with those draft
picks and it's just amazing to me that
how quickly his career really
deteriorated and now here we are to the
point where he's getting a new start
somewhere else and the eagles are moving
on to whoever else they they happen to
find and i don't see a veteran
quarterback going to philadelphia
because why would you go there if you
think you have to compete for the
starting job if you have a chance to go
somewhere else to definitely be the
starter
one guy that i'm fascinated by
as a potential eagles quarterback is
nick foles and what would be his third
stint with the team he was there
2012 originally as a third round draft
pick traded to the rams for sam bradford
then signed as a free agent after a
season with the chiefs super bowl mvp
the guy that they said will move on from
after carson wentz became the franchise
quarterback and the guy they chose to
keep now you could bring foles back and
it could be jalen hurts with foals as
the backup who knows there are a bunch
of different ways they can go but it
will be i believe two quarterbacks
whether it's a rookie with hertz or a
veteran with hurts they'll have two
quarterbacks about whom they feel good
and they'll move forward in that way and
try to rebuild a franchise that just won
a super bowl a little over three years
ago and what a different team it is now
with nick ciriani as the head coach with
carson wentz gone and with a quarterback
depth chart that at least is 50 percent
settled but 50 completely and totally
uncertain and the only thing we know is
they won't have carson once as of march
17 at 401 pm eastern let's look at this
now from the colts perspective and i
think the colts
got the guy that they wanted and got the
guy that they needed and they have the
reunion with frank wreck if anyone was
going to get carson wentz back to where
he was before whatever it was that
happened in 2020 was it the jalen hurts
draft pick was it something else was his
relationship with doug peterson was it
his relationship with someone else what
caused the guy who in 2019
single-handedly turned around a 5-17 and
took them to the playoffs
and maybe would have beat the seahawks
if he hadn't been knocked out of the
game early thanks to an illegal hit from
janae and cloudy that was neither flag
nor fined when he got a concussion in
that game i mean carson wentz is the
last guy expected to lose it in 2020. so
can
frank reich turn this guy around it's a
huge financial investment but if they
can get him back to where he was holy
crap this is a potential super bowl team
oh no question about it mike this is a
team that was in the top ten in both
offense and defense last season with
philip rivers quarterback and obviously
a declining philip rivers at quarterback
and he didn't turn the ball over as much
as he did in his final season with the
chargers but even if they get the
mid-level play
from carson wentz that he gave the
eagles in 2018 and 2019 this is a team
that's probably going to go to the
playoffs it's probably going to cost the
colts a first round draft pick which
frankly they will gladly give up if that
leads to to a playoff team and in
success in the playoffs now we know
carson wentz has not had that success in
the playoffs yet but he certainly has
shown it at least in one season that he
can be that franchise guy and he was
having a terrific season when he had
that knee injury he was on pace for over
4 000 passing yards and 40 touchdowns he
still had 33 touchdowns which was second
in the nfl that season after missing the
last last four games after that knee
injury so he's shown he can be that guy
it's now a matter of frank reich and
press taylor getting that back out of
carson wentz but carson wentz i know
respects frank reich and loves frank
reich and that's going to help him and
he's going to listen to frank wright and
frank wright obviously believes he can
get back carson wentz back to that level
or they wouldn't have made this trade
mike there's just no way
and i think it's the only place that
carson wentz wanted to go jay glazer
reported earlier today that the bears
never actually made an offer and that
takes me back to
the the rumor slash report that emerged
super bowl weekend from howard eskin of
wip who's also the eagle sideline
reporter i just wonder who from the
eagles planted that notion that the
bears were going to offer first round
pick nick foles tarik cohen
for carson wentz and a draft pick from
the eagles that that i think was aimed
at scaring the colts off of their
position and drawn jaworski had said two
second round picks is what the colts
offered maybe maybe two second round
picks became
uh the the the final package through
negotiation with the possibility of a
first-round pick and a third-round pick
going to philadelphia but regardless
the cults were the only ever team only
team that ever made sense for carson
wentz and if i'm him just think about
that the differences in the fan base the
differences in the expectation level
he's going to a place that has been
shell shocked by quarterback movement in
recent years and it all started with the
retirement of andrew luck then they
pivoted to jacobi brissett and then they
give philip rivers a try i don't think
the colts fans are going to be nearly as
skeptical as bears fans would have been
and it's going to be nothing like the
experience he would have had if he'd
stayed in philadelphia as the starter i
think the colts fans are going to
embrace him because
they understand hey
if this guy plays like he's capable of
playing we are
a legitimate contender and we've we've
fixed that that that hole in the
franchise that emerged when andrew luck
retired now the injury issue is
something to be worried about and
they're used to that with andrew luck
but if this guy can get back to anything
close to how he was before 2020 the
colts will be a factor in the afc and uh
you know if not they will have spent
some money they've been holding a ton of
cap space they have to on a four-year
rolling average spend a certain amount
of money in relation to the salary cap
and this isn't going to hurt them
they're able to do it now because they
got so much cap space they don't need to
worry about their budget they
they just factor in carson wentz as a
guy who's on the team and you otherwise
work out your budget for everyone else
they'll be able to do that they'll be
able to operate they'll be able to go
out and try to make the team better and
maybe they can create some buzz and be
one of these teams that attracts the
free agents who can't find long-term
deals and who are saying i'm going to go
to a team that i think will be a
contender the colts now are on that list
they already were but i think they're
even more clearly on that list now that
they've addressed the quarterback
situation shireen
yeah no question mike and you know they
had that band-aid approach to their
quarterback position after andrew luck
surprised them with his retirement right
before the start of the season they had
the one-year starter and jacoby bersette
then they had the one-year starter in
phillip rivers but if you look back over
their history carson wentz is going to
be their fifth assuming he's healthy on
opening day he'll be their fifth
straight opening day starter that's
that's different different quarterback
five consecutive years uh for the colts
and frank wright it'll be his fourth
starting quarterback since he's been
there but they think they've settled
that now with carson wentz that he is
going to be the guy long term going
forward and you mentioned the fan base
is going to be in love with carson wentz
they are there's going to be a long
honeymoon period there because they
think they found their next guy after
andrew luck finally to take the reins
for a long period of time it's also a
better media market for a quarterback
mike because the philadelphia and you
think about even chicago media markets
there would be much more pressure on
carson wentz in those two markets
he's going to face a lot less pressure
from that standpoint in a smaller media
market in indianapolis i'm not saying
they're not tough i'm just saying it's a
smaller media market there's less
scrutiny and i think he's going to enjoy
that and i certainly think that will
help his confidence and his revival not
to mention his offensive line is going
to be much much better than he had in
philadelphia this past year
see one of the things that the eagles
were kind of quietly
saying to justify sticking with carson
wentz they had 14 different offensive
line combinations last year 14. they
were losing guys in the preseason they
were losing guys before training there
was no preseason they were losing guys
before training camp even began last
year so that they have had a difficult
time on the offensive line especially
last year and and they don't have that
in indianapolis now they got to figure
out what they're doing at left tackle
now that anthony castanzo has retired
and there's even talk that that quentin
nelson will move to tackle which may or
may not be a good thing for the colts
but they've got the nucleus to have a
good offensive line and they've got the
cap space to go out and buy up some guys
to make it even better than it currently
is so i think that this has the
potential to work for wence and work for
the colts and the
the big point is there was no one else
where it would have worked there was
nowhere else where he could have gone
and felt like he's walking into a good
situation where he's going to get the
benefit of the doubt from the media
where he's going to get the benefit of
the doubt from the fans where he has
someone there with whom he's worked
before it all lined up perfectly the
moment that it looked like he wanted out
during the season the only place that
made sense was the colts it was always
pointing to the colts and back to the
eagles to consider that they got real
value for a contract that in their
perspective was a hot potato deal they
didn't have to give up net assets to get
rid of the contract that has over 40
million guaranteed over the next two
years they got something back that in
and of itself is a win this isn't brock
osweiler this isn't jared goff they got
net draft assets for that contract
because the colts needed carson wentz
now they didn't need him so much they
gave up a clear first rounder but it
probably is going to be a first rounder
in 2022 and that's absolutely the best
the eagles could have hoped for shereen
mike when you consider what they gave up
to get him
the bad contract they gave him
they did win a super bowl in his time
there i realized he was not the
quarterback of the team but maybe they
don't go win the super bowl if he
doesn't do what he did in the regular
season to get them to the playoffs to
give them you know some some home games
there and everything else he did to get
him into the playoffs was this worth it
to draft carson wentz and do what they
did
well i look at it this way during the
period of time that carson wentz was on
the team they won the first super bowl
in franchise history yep so yes it was
worth it and he he had a key hand in
positioning
the eagles for the number one seed in
the nfc if nick foles is the wire to
wire quarterback in 2017 they're not the
number one seed and they're likely not
winning the super bowl so yes from that
perspective
it was worth it and um you know this
gets back to the the philosophical
debate and i i don't know where i come
down in this regard the
the quarterback
who you hope is going to transform your
franchise and be your 15-year starter
versus all the stuff you give up to get
him or the stuff that you decline in
order to draft him whether it was last
year whatever the bengals said no to
from the dolphins in hindsight
maybe you do the deal take justin
herbert plus all the other stuff and
you're better off than if you only have
joe burrow because you get your
franchise quarterback and a bunch of
extra lottery tickets that's the
question
how sure is a sure thing in the nfl how
many of these franchise quarterbacks
actually lead a team to a championship
and is it better to have more of the
tickets where you scratch off the silver
metallic paint and you see what's under
it because
i'm a firm believer the the more swings
you take the more tickets you scratch
the more likely you are to put together
a team that's going to have a solid
nucleus instead of putting all the eggs
in one basket and hoping that that guy
becomes a transcendent player because it
it just doesn't happen that often where
that one guy becomes the guy when you
when you say we're either giving up a
bunch of stuff to get him or we're
saying no to a bunch of stuff we could
get to keep him that that guy becomes
the savior of the franchise who vaults
you to multiple championships
i
completely agree with you mike and you
look what the kansas city chiefs did
they were a really good team that had a
chance to win a super bowl with alex
smith at quarterback i mean we all liked
them we all thought they had a chance to
win it yet they traded up to get patrick
mahomes because they loved patrick
mahomes so much and you look at the
saints we're thinking about doing the
same thing despite having drew brees
then you look at a team last year the
lions who had the third pick overall
could have drafted their future
franchise quarterback but said nah we're
good we have matthew stafford a year
later they've moved on from matthew
stafford and they're rebuilding with
with jared goff maybe if they had
drafted justin herbert at that point
maybe even tua who knows but if they had
drafted a quarterback there they saw
their quarterback woes last year then
they trade matthew stafford this year
and they get all those additional draft
picks but they already have their
quarterback they don't have to take on
jared goff so i'm completely with you i
don't care if you have a guy you truly
believe in
we talk about the packers last year i
see why they drafted jordan love even if
jordan love never plays a down for the
packers maybe they'll be able to trade
him and get even more for him in the
future and it certainly benefited i
think aaron rodgers this year because
i'm not sure he would have won the mvp
award if he wasn't looking back and had
that chip on his shoulder that jordan
love came in as a first round draft pick
to replace him
it's a fascinating philosophical
discussion there are no right answers
until we know what the answers are and
then we can look back and say that team
did the right thing that team did the
right thing that team didn't do the
right thing and that's one of the one of
the the frustrating aspects if you're
working for a team and trying to figure
out the best way through this and there
are different approaches but you know
the chiefs go all in they make the move
to get patrick mahomes and it works if
that if that guy ends up being
that once in a generation player and you
don't find out until he gets to the nfl
that he is or he isn't but if he is
you got something and the eagles thought
they had it with carson wentz and
i i i think that there are books to be
written on what really happened between
the eagles and carson wentz behind the
scenes that caused them to be compelled
to move on from him and the real
question is was 2020 an aberration was
this the equivalent of ben
roethlisberger's third season in
pittsburgh or peyton manning's fourth
season in indianapolis both progressed
but both turned it around the colts are
going to be hoping that
he turns it around and that they can not
just get back to the playoffs but win
some playoff games and
um
who knows now the other thing to
remember i i feel compelled to say this
because we talk about these deals as if
they're official not official until
march 17 at 401 pm eastern and either
team can back out not that i'm rooting
for that but i do kind of like a little
chaos and
just the statistics right chances are at
some point with enough of these trades
that are done but not done in advance of
the first day of the league year one of
these days one of these years one of
these trades is going to fall through
and the the moment we don't talk about
it anymore shireen that's the moment it
will happen
yeah absolutely mike and and it doesn't
become official and it's not official
and either team can back out at any
point until it becomes official and we
we've seen that in other deals
especially around the trade deadline
where a guy doesn't pass a physical or
something but we've never seen it at
this point but at some point you figure
it's got to happen
yeah and you know i've never heard any
more details about jared goff's physical
that was the one
let's wait and see what the lions do
because of the thumb surgery that he had
late in the regular season and it would
be an easy way for the lions to say you
know what we really don't want to do
this we can maybe get a better offer
from someone else so i i haven't heard
anything about it they acted like they
were going to do the physical fairly
quickly there hasn't been any reporting
that i'm aware of one way or the other
and i think we'd have heard about it
because things have been so damn slow
since the aftermath of the super bowl
but that's one way if a team gets
remorse and doesn't just want to simply
renege on the deal
the doctor just fails the guy on the
physical and we've seen that happen
different doctors have different views
about the overall health and well-being
of a player and uh it would be naive to
assume that the teams don't have a way
of letting the doctor know which way
they'd like that physical to come out
one other point about this from the from
the colts perspective the colts called
the raiders about derek carr reportedly
and the colts were told that derrick
carr
is not available so
the eagles or the cults excuse me
tried to get carr
the raiders didn't even have a
discussion so this isn't a situation of
of uh engaging in trade talks they're
they're keeping derek carr they're all
in for derek carr and maybe that's their
position until they find someone better
and then they make the move and then
derek carr would be available because
mike mayok always talks about that the
gm of the team but it sounds like
they're still in hang up the phone mode
whenever anyone asks about derek carr
yeah and it sounds like they're more
likely mike to trade marcus mariota and
there is interest in marcus mariota so
it's going to be interesting what
happens with the raiders as we go
forward there's so many of these teams
who are kind of on the edge that you you
know if they trade their quarterback
you're not going to be surprised but
what are you going to do at the
quarterback position you've got to
upgrade if you're going to change your
quarterback
if you have one i realize the colts
didn't have one after philip rivers
retired but if you have one it's got to
be a definite upgrade over the one you
have just like a head coach if you're
changing head coaches you got to make
sure you find a better one than the one
you have mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports